ولكن هذه المرة على ارض الواقع.
ولما لا قد تكون ارض الحدث هي
بوتين. وهنا اعلنت موسكو انها
تستخدم جيلا جديدا من الليزر
الغربي بالاسلحة متواصل ولا
ينقطع عن الاوكران. واصبح لديهم
اخافة اوكران انما هي رسالة
للغرب الامريكان. فاقماركم
المعارك دائرة في ارجاء اوكرانيا
وبشتى الاسلحة. والخسائر على
يعطل جميع انظمة استطلاع الاقمار
الصناعية التابعة لعدو محتمل
المقبل. هذه ليس فكرة غريبة.
انها الواقعة. ماذا عن الحرب
خرج نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسي
المسؤول عن التطوير العسكري.
الليزر. بروسوف يعود ويؤكد ان
هذا في الاساس سلاح ليزر. سلاح
في غضون خمس ثوان. خمس ثوان فقط.
احتاجها الليزر ليدمر تلك
الصناعية لم تعد ذات جدوى. الان
ومع وجود بيريسف كما يقولها
وشيئا فشيئا سنرى الاسلحة التي
لا يعرفها العالم الا عبر الصور
بيريسفيت. ولكن ان كانت صحيحة
فان روسيا قد حققت فعلا تقدما في
اوكرانيا. لكن بوتين باظهاره
لسلاح الليزر بيسفد. لم يكن هدفه
فيت. موسكو اوضحت انها تستخدم
اسلحة مشابهة لليزر بيرفيت وهي
سنوات. بحسب صحيفة رويترز. كلما
ازداد الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا
بوتين المرعب. لكن لا احد يعرف
الكثير عن قدراته. وكعادة الروس.
امداد قوات الصواريخ باعداد
كبيرة من هذا السلاح. ويمكنه ان
بوتين الحربية. لكل سلاح قوي يتم
صناعة سلاح ذي فعالية اقوى ليبطل
الاوكرانية? في الحروب لا يكون
هناك انتصارات بدون خسائر.
نماذج اولية تدعى زاديرا.
المعلومات ليست دقيقة بحسب
نسبة للراهب الارثوذكسي الكسندر
بيرفد المحارب الكبير من العصور
العلمي قبل سنوات. لكن القوى
الكبرى مثل الولايات المتحدة
يخلد اسمه بسلاح يذكرهم بقوة
الكسندر وشجاعته. قوة بيرثفيد.
كيلومتر فوق سطح الارض. عن اي
قوة نتحدث يا سادة واي سلاح هذا
ينشغل العالم بالاسلحة الفتاكة
والمدمرة واسلحة الدمار الشامل
دقيق الحجم لكنه كاسح في
التدمير. نعم. لقد ظهر ليزر
منه الطائرات. سريع كسرعة الضوء.
صغير لا يحتاج لناقلات. قد يكون
اسلحة الليزر. وهو اتجاه يحظى
باهتمام كبير من القوى النووية
مجموعة من الاسلحة الجديدة.
فمنها صاروخ باليستي جديد عابر
قارات ورأس حربي نووي صغير يمكن
تركيبه في صواريخ كروز وطائرات
الغربية الى جارتها. ويعتقد ان
هذه الاسلحة ليست الا ليزر بيرس
الامريكية والغربية في زمن قريب
الاجابة لدى زعيم روسيا الاول?
القوية في اوكرانيا. يستخدم
لاحراق الطائرات المسيرة، وانها
الاخرى مثل الولايات المتحدة
والصين. وكان استخدام الليزر
الاسلحة الحرارية الجوية ووداعا
للمسيرات. لما ايها الدب الروسي؟
والصين وروسيا تعمل على اعداد
انواع مختلفة من هذه الاسلحة منذ
الرغم من اختلافها في الحجم بين
الطرفين موجودة وبقوة. الدعم
ثلاثمائة. وللصواريخ الباليستية
هناك الحديدية. وهكذا. وبينما
مفعول السلاح السابق. اي لكل داء
دواء وهكذا هي استراتيجية بيع
بالاسلحة كلما اظهرت روسيا بعضا
من اسلحتها وتقنياتها وانظمتها.
الروس فهل يتم استخدام هذا
الليزر ضد الاقمار الصناعية
كهرومغناطيسي واسع النطاق. سيحل
محل الاسلحة التقليدية في العقد
تخشاه انت. هل علمتم ما هو
المقصود? انه سلاح بوتين المرعب.
الذبابة وهو يمشي بسرعة الضوء يا
له من سلاح ذي مواصفات مرعبة.
لتعمية الاقمار الصناعية او حتى
حرقها اقرب الى عالم الخيال
طائرات سويتش بليد الامريكية
المسيرة. فضلا عن المسيرات
تنشر كذلك بعضا من اسلحتها
السرية بمواجهة تدفق الاسلحة
التركية بمقدار. كل هذه الاسلحة
سببت بعضا من الصداع في رأس
بمدارات جدا مما يؤدي الى تعطلها
اثناء التحليق بسبب استخدام اشعة
الذي يمكنه تدمير وتعطيل اسلحة
الاعداء من على بعد الف وخمسمائة
نطاق واسع ويمكنه تعطيل الاقمار
الصناعية حتى الف وخمسمائة
بتجربة وقال انها احرقت طائرة
مسيرة على بعد خمسة كيلو مترات
كيلومتر. ما هذه القوة الخارقة.
بوريسوف لا يزال يتحدث واستشهد
المسيرة وعلى بعد خمسمائة متر.
سلاح عجيب. في روسيا يتم بالفعل
فلاديمير بوتين
الامر طبيعيا والاسلحة متوقعة
ومعروفة لدى العالم رغم قوتها
الخارقة. لكن وفي ذلك اليوم اعلن
بوتين عن سلاح روسيا المعجزة.
يوري بوريسوف في مؤتمر في موسكو
وقال ان يجري نشره بالفعل على
انه السلاح الخارق لموسكو. سلاح
يخترق الفولاذ وقوته تذيب وتتحطم
الوسطى الذي لقي حتفه في معركة
طاحنة قائد ابى الروس الا ان
الليزر لم يتحدث بعد يا اصدقاء.
اطلق هذا الليزر اسم بيرسفيد
فهم لا يتحدثون كثيرا ويتركون
اسلحتهم هي التي تتحدث. لكن
ما نوع السلاح الذي تمتلكه؟ وهل
على الغرب ان يقلق حقا؟ معجزة
مسيرة نووية تحت الماء وسلاح
اسرع من الصوت. والى هنا لا زال
تهتم لهذه الاسلحة وتستمر
بصنعها. لكن وعلى غير العادة خرج
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين في
عام الفين وثمانية عشر وكشف عن
هو هذا الذي لا يعرفه الغربيون.
عندما اعلن الروس عن سلاح
من رؤوس حربية ونووية وقنابل
كهرومغناطيسية. كانت روسيا كذلك
الاسلحة في الدول العظمى. فمثلا
للطائرات هناك الباتريوت والاس
الليزر. قالوا وداعا للاقمار
الصناعية. وانتهى الخوف من
لمعرفتهم بقوة سلاح موسكو. ولكن
لانهم لا يعرفونه اصلا. اي سلاح
انه ليزر روسيا المخيف. ورعب
الغرب هذه المرة ليس لانهم
على مدى التاريخ العمل بصمت هو
اخطر من اسلحة الدمار الشامل.
تقول روسيا حارب عدوك بالسلاح
الذي يخشاه. لا بالسلاح الذي
خلق ليذوب الحديد وليخترق الفضاء
ويصيب الهدف حتى وان كان بحجم